I know this sounds insane but I think I
have some kind of ghost or evil spirit
and I have the worst nightmares Chrissy
Teigen is getting no sleep that's for a
bit the 34 year old guy candid on
Instagram late Wednesday night to let
fans know she's been struggling with the
same nightmare like I will go to bed
super early and I will sleep so long and
I will wake up soaking wet because I
have just the most terrible nightmare
it's always the same nightmare the model
didn't share exactly what the nightmare
is but she made it clear she's had
enough I'm tired of it and it's ruining
my life and so I'm sleeping in a
different room tonight and we'll see if
this makes a difference in true chrissy
fashion she went on to cut off the
critics before they had a chance to come
at her i understand is a very privileged
to have an extra room but i do quite a
guest around her guests sleep when they
come over there's no guests here so i'm
sleeping here tonight okay we love that
she's taking matters into her own hand
but here's a thought girl needs to stop
watching the movie saw before bed
one step at a time the mom of two
promise to let fans know how it goes
but we haven't heard from her since oh
gosh while we're waiting for an update
we're hoping Chrissie is now nightmare
free that would be my absolute dream the
TV personality noted she's starting work
soon and needs the energy she and hubby
John Legend brought plenty of that to
their Super Bowl commercial which aired
just last month ET was on set we were
just like let's just have fun and
scene-by-scene and there'll be a lot of
improv obviously I mean when you think
comedy and probably think John Legend
naturally another thing to be excited
for Chrissy's Court which is about to be
in session on kwibi in April I love the
fact that she has Chrissy's core it's
one of my favorite things I think it's
my favorite thing she's ever done and I
really when they told me the concept for
the show I was like he sold me on the
clock I was like this is I can't think
of a more natural thing for you to do
when they say no case is too petty like
these cases are the pettiest of petty
but it's so fun watching her be the
arbiter between them oh and I get to sit
and wear a robe and it just it's heaven
[Music]